so today we're going to talk about your
favorite player who's your favorite
player who Paul Morphy good answer
but we have a different answer today
five-time world champion from India yeah
well it's not you
he was insinuating he was the five-time
for all shades I thought from India but
five-time world champion
his name is Vishwanath on Anand right
and where is he from is he from the
north of the South the South good guess
right from your favorite town Chennai
and we're going to look at a non beating
people very quickly I don't mean he
played fast he didn't play fast I mean
that he won in less than 20 moves
against grandmasters now when you apply
when you guys play grandmasters you
probably win but you don't win in less
than 20 moves do you right you
understand yeah he's not English alright
so his first game is against your
favorite Ukrainian player Vasilyev on
talk
also known as Yvan truck ok Anand is
black and he played the most exciting
opening ever the Russian defense he
should slow down but he was Russian no
nothing all right
Knight f6 we call it the Petrov defence
in America and white took the pawn
now a big beginner mistake is for black
to take the pawn and black can get in
trouble because after Queen Queen f3
after Queen e2 exactly now the Black
Knight and the black King are lined up a
lot of beginners now make another
mistake Knight f6 and now white can
actually win the game in one move how
does white win a free Queen it's free I
tells you you with the right answer
hey that is the right answer you don't
know good job
okay with the wrong answer Arjun 96
check the Queens attacking the King and
the Knights attacking the Queen now
anam didn't do that anon played d6
attacking the knight like all
grandmasters do and then after the
knight retreated he took the pawn and
white played d4 now I did tell you a
funny story
in 1988 Anand also had this position in
fact this game was played in 1988 so
there you go later in the year he had
this position and his opponent played
Knight c3 you see how the Knights are
attacking each other okay and now Anand
made the losing move I move five can I
help you g5 is okay the mean move is
Knight takes Knight
what's the losing movin on played hmm
hold on let me think about it
no that's what my color would say right
my coming wouldn't say no all right you
could throw it in the trash we'll wait
for you to come back now that was quick
okay so Vishy Anand played Bishop f5
protecting his Knight and he was playing
the Columbian Grandmaster Alonzo Zapata
Zapata now lives in Atlanta Georgia
who's been to Atlanta Georgia actually I
haven't so I'll put my hand down what
you've been to Atlanta Georgia what
about Georgia Georgia okay and now
Zapata played Queen e2 the Queen pins
the knight and the Knights attacked
twice and anon did something you would
never do here he gave up yeah now let's
pretend black protects his knight then
white attacks it and then I can move and
a flat protects his knight with a queen
then Knight d5
I have rar what's a good move for blacks
Queen don't raise your hand because
there's no good answer you
well yeah but what's a good move for his
queen
he plays Queenie six there's a Royal
fork and a family fork okay like let's
say you're at home eating dinner and
there's three or four of you but you
only have one fork you're deaf work is
called a family fork right okay and if
you don't fall into the family fork now
you'll lose your knight because it's
pinned okay so this game didn't go like
that an unguent losing five moves white
played d4 d5 and they develop their
pieces Wow black developed a lot of
pieces does he get a prize for the most
developing again f5 so black has all of
his minor pieces out does white have all
his minor pieces out terrible boo okay
so Queen b3 attacking the pawn does that
develop a minor piece no and Anand
played Queen to d6 now a non can castle
either way
white played Knight to d2 and a non
Castle queenside and a von Schuch played
a fork now most of you are like wait a
minute
white just fork two of black's pieces
White's winning but White has all of his
pieces on the back row here and black
has all of his pieces out so he's going
to try to checkmate white because most
of white's pieces are really far from
his king what's better forking to pieces
or checkmating checkmating so now an on
played a really mean move Bishop h4
attacking the rook and Anand has a lot
of pieces near White's King did he
Vaughn sure give his rook away and cry
now he played rook f1 and said that's my
ruck okay and then he played [ __ ]
ship h3r are getting near the king let's
pretend that he takes the bishop
attending is fun right then we go queen
g6 check now what is what you do King h1
9f to check now what is what he do rip
takes now we're going to play queen g1
checkmate right what is y going to do
about that
wow the class is quiet you queens it now
you're just being silly queen d1 is what
you meant now I could play rook e8
threatening rook e1 check and White has
good development no so Evangel didn't do
that because he get crushed
he played Queen c2 Queen g6 I don't see
what blacks threatening is black
threatening anything what's he
threatening Queen takes G to me do you
think white stopped that or he let black
do that
he sought it he played Knight b3 now his
queen is protecting his pawn rook F a
knight a three rookie a and now the
losing move King H one putting his King
in the corner and now an on did
something he didn't see based on the
overworked theme maybe he was overworked
he played the amazing move Knight F to
check what do you think white played
what's that he took the knight otherwise
you can give up okay now he a non
tricked them when the work goes here
there's two white pieces that defend f1
but Anand made one of those pieces move
away then Rickey one was made how do you
make either the rook or the bishop move
away
you can make it move away and that's
what he did he made the rook move away
how did he do that
how did black make a move and the white
rook had to move away from defense
because the rook is defending something
else Arjun this ship takes G to check
did he play King takes G to illegal if
he plays rook takes G to now rook e1
check is annoying who's winning
black wait white has good defense of his
King right all those pieces defending
his king no terrible now always played
Bishop f1 and now would you check me
with a rook or the Queen why the rook
why the Queen yeah they're both me right
yeah so white resigned because he didn't
want to get baited oh poor him poor baby
okay so King each one was the losing
move overlooking this trick and then he
gave up and then an on became world
champion you never heard of the other
guy ah I mean you at home heard of him
all right next anon was playing I think
this guy's name is Rufus okay so they
played the open Sicilian okay Anand was
black and black white said oh boy I'm
going to double your pawns okay
now who has more bishops black or white
black now both sides have one color
bishop what color to both sides have a
white squared bishop or a dark squared
bishop both sides have a white squared
bishop that means blacks dark square
bishop will dominate if you don't
believe me wait to see the rest of the
game then you'll believe me okay so f5
terrible move giving away the e-file
square root of the night or you could
footboard okay or you could go crazy
ah wait what's going on pushing shift
and alt all right so f5 is no good that
makes the night better and it makes the
bishop better now I not wanted to play
Bishop h6 but there's a slight problem
why can't black play Bishop h6 you the
Queen will take it but an on took care
of that h5 now when he plays Bishop h6
will the Queen take it no because the
the rook is defending it yeah okay so
Ananse pretty sneaky
so Bishop e2 h4 going for a queen Bishop
h6 did white save his queen or he let
him take his queen saved it now you
gotta be careful because this Knight is
attacked so you can't move your queen
anywhere you got to move your queen and
protect your knight now I'm done I got
to wind this up attacked white tonight
again how did an on attack the Black
Knight and don't say e5 Arjun Queen b6
okay White Castle into this pin that's a
lot a lot of stuff attacking the knight
how did White protect his Knight you
don't want to lose your night do you so
what do you do about it how do you
protect it more its attack two times
it's defended one time you just give
your knight away and cry how do you
protect it we got to move a piece to
protect that night arjun rook a d1 now
there's two pieces at defending the
knight and two pieces attacking it but
Anand saw three moves ahead and he said
wait a minute
my dark squared bishop is really really
really good because you've got all these
pieces on dark squares so a non plague
Queen takes Knight check and white did
something crazy he resigned let's
pretend he did
design Queen takes Queen Knight takes
Queen is black up a piece three pieces
two pieces
how does why get his fees back rip takes
tonight and now raise your hand who can
find the winning fork if you do you'll
have two forks at dinner not just the
family for which your own Fork
in other hands go up like I want my own
Fork
you would left-handed go out what Bishop
III check forking the king and rook
don't you hate when that happens
unless you have black and you like what
happens yeah okay so after Queen b6
whites actually losing he shouldn't have
castled when he cancelled he lined up
his King and knight on this diagonal and
there was no defense also f5 was a bad
move just let the Bishop cotton attack
if this pawn was back a square then
white would be safe so too many pawn
moves from white too many bishops for
black too many tactics are are okay
another uh non-game not the whole game a
little bit of the game was against court
onsen from your favorite country now in
this position blacks attacking White's
King he's got a bishop here he's got a
rook here his Queens coming his bishops
coming and and white better be careful
except for one thing
white wasn't careful at all that's why
you've never heard of Kurt Hanson you've
heard of this Ian on never heard him
either Queen the g6 and white didn't see
the threat hold on okay now black has a
crushing threat but white didn't see it
and then black played it white was like
I'm gonna win upon I'm the greatest and
white said this is a checked and it's
attacked again he said while I'm the
greatest player ever and he took the
point on e5 and he was like oh boy an
ons going to take and then I'm going to
take
and I'm a pawn up and then I'll do this
and so forth okay but Anand he didn't
take this pawn he played the most
crushing move ever and then white cried
and then white gave up
what's the crushing move that anan
played that his opponent didn't see
raise your hand if you're as good as
Anand who can find the winning move for
black it takes advantage of a pin now
this is the advanced class we have to
take advantage of this pin we have to
punish white for his indolence and his
insolence right clean aware if you play
Queen to h5 threatening checkmate widel
play Queen takes Queen
stop being checkmate but threatening
checkmate is correct but you have to
move your queen somewhere else where the
Queen can't take it
have a seat Arjen try to figure it out
anyone Bensimon you the back queen g3
shocking everybody except Arjen now
pawn takes Queen is risky due to the
fact that it's illegal well you could
try it then the rook would be checking
your King not only did you guys not see
that white didn't see it either because
if why did see it he wouldn't have
allowed it now Queen takes h2 is tough
it's rough I tell Zia what's the only
move that stops Queen h2 mate because
you don't want to get checkmated right
so if you were white how would you stop
that checkmate Arjen h3 instead what did
white do Arjen he resigned let's play
Age 3 well I gave the answer away
because the computer was too hungry
takes checkmate some of you don't know
why it's checked me because you forgot
about this Bishop now you know it's
checkmate right did white do a good job
defending his King
now nothing next to his king so taking
on e5 that was the worst move ever white
should have defended his pawn with like
this Chevy one or Queen f3 or Queen e1
or rook F something to defend his pawn
not just let black take it and checkmate
them that's pretty good attack bishops
doing a good job queen is rook is
everybody's happy except white alright
and the last anon game was against the
famous chess teacher
Arthur Cogan now we have a saying those
who can't teach and this guy proves it
okay a lot of people buy chess books so
they're like wow that guy is a great
player knafeh teach chess like look at
me I teach chess am ia great player
oh wait the exception proves the rule
okay never mind so most people who teach
chess a lot if they play at the top
level they get checkmated every move but
if they play little kids they get like
60% that's pretty good right right Arjun
60% is good if you've got 60% and you
played 30 games how many points would
you get yeah hmm anyone now you 18 there
you go okay now in this position it's
too complicated because how is white's
bishop on g8 what happened okay so what
this position actually has equal
material and Anand did something very
dangerous don't do it in real life don't
do that either he walked into a fork ow
so Anand played King f8 and said gimme
gimme gimme gimme gimme your bishop and
then the guy who had white he called the
arbiter and said my opponent keeps
talking he said gimme gimme gimme gimme
gimme
okay now Kogan is like oh boy a fork 96
check at an ons like I'm
not afraid of your discovered attack
King takes bishop and then Kogan plate a
discovered attack because if he moves
his knight the Queen will be checking
the King now if he moves his knight here
we just take it if he moves his knight
here the Queen attacks the king the
Knight attacks the Queen right how does
block how does black escape he can say
both of them you Queen to f7 and black
is safe so instead since white can't win
a queen white decided to win a rook
rooks are pretty good right how did
white win a ruck you and the Wadden off
your hands up you your hands up which
one on g7 Knight g7 really all he took
his own pawn backwards oh nine c7 check
see how its check and he attacks the
rook and then I was like whatever take
my rook I dare you I double dare you
so you did now White has a lot of pieces
in front of his King like this one this
one this one in this one wait are those
near White's King No so a nun's like I
have a good idea let's check late our
opponent anon wants to play Queen G to
me so what move did he make to threaten
Queen G to me with advantage Arjun he
played Bishop h3 threatening Queen G to
mate if you were white how would you
stop Queen takes G to mate it is a tough
question
it's really tough raise your hand if you
know the answer how did white stop
checkmate in one if you're white you
don't want your opponent to checkmate
you yes
Queen takes his own pawn and that is
I've soaked like Queens XD 2 million if
you're gonna make it illegal move make
it a good one
yes incorrect you did not resign he was
tough
what g3 all right now on on five-time
world champion you're some little kid so
anon can play Queen G to me he can jump
over the pawn he's five-time world
champion
can he do that hey it's not letting an
undo it okay so how did an on get his
Queen to g2 if you can't jump over his
pawn Bishop g2 that wasn't really my
question I want black to play Queen g2
because that's checkmate checkmate is
good because you win what vitamin is
checkmate have four check me you if only
if only you knew that but you didn't
know it yeah I know I Queen takes e4
threatening checkmate
are there a lot of good defenses there's
a lot of good defenses
there's resins offer a draw lose on time
what's the defense well hold on this was
going to be illegal you yes I predicted
the illegal move good teacher right your
move is illegal I predicted it too you
see my bishop on b6 and you see your
King on g1 ah thought you hate when that
happens the reason you shouldn't play f3
is it because it's illegal never play f3
hi
so since f3 is illegal are there are
there a lot of good defenses to me yeah
Cogan found the only defense Arjun he
resigned he gave up but wait his pieces
are doing a good job defending his king
right no and you thought that black only
had two pieces attacking but this Bishop
is pinning the F pawn that's a good
Bishop
so black used all of his pieces to
attack and white used none of his pieces
to defend
so Arthur Cogan he was crying when he
walked out of the room because he lost
and what did it non say to him what you
think white play good oh good that's a
good answer although he won so he
wouldn't congratulate his opponent he
said Arthur class dismissed
they're like what yeah exactly exactly
yes can i play what's the rules under
what no I can't play them 6:01